I don't understand why we got a why we got a cap like this. Why
you got a Why you Why you got a cap like this? I just don't get
it. Pokey ain't standing on business for some dude who can't
even crack 2K, all right? Ain't happening. Sykkuno was propping
up like the entire Twitch e-girl ecosystem. It's like, "Well,
I didn't really like the guy that much, so I just blew him."
And it's like, "Wha huh?" You shouldn't blow the guy just cuz
you don't want to have
Okay, hold on. Let's go to Let's go to Best Friends his Twitter.
Just recently, I think this is 2 days ago now, we had a new Sykkuno
accuser drop, okay? This is going to be up and down for us, all
right? We It's going to be difficult to get just right cuz in
some ways
this girl is like Tim In my opinion, like obviously lying or
misconstruing
There's There This is not the best one,
But, it does lean into the pattern. The pattern is very much
the same. All right, so this is the new accuser. This is Leia,
okay? New Sykkuno victim comes forward saying he finished inside
her without protection in Evo Las Vegas hotel room.
Okay, this This doesn't This isn't an
This would be an accusation if you agreed to not have or if you
agreed to have with a condom. So, we'll see how this goes.
We'll see how this goes. Oh. >> to Evo Las Vegas >> Spoiler
note, what the hell?
>> But, I wasn't alone. I shared a hotel room with Sykkuno.
>> But, I didn't know
that he had other intentions. Um
>> Sharing a hotel room with one guy, who could have guessed
what would happen? Hold on.
That's true, okay? I would agree. She should have her guard up
immediately when the idea of like sharing a hotel room comes
up. Immediately have her guard up, okay?
But, he says something
He says something that makes me think a little bit about >> ask
him
>> to share a room with me. I just simply asked him, "Hey,
are you going to Evo Las Vegas?"
He said yes, and I said, "Oh, I'm trying to look at I'm trying
to I'm trying to go this year. I'm looking at hotels, and everything's
so expensive.
Do you pretty much have like any recommendations?" Like I know
he lives in Las Vegas. And he said, "Oh, you're planning on coming?
I actually
>> So, now right from the outset, I can't say for sure,
but depending on how well they knew each other, which I think
there's a clip that explains how well they knew each other.
You're like unattractive young woman, and you're asking this
guy for recommendations on where to stay in the city he lives
in. I feel like if you don't know what's sort of soft being peddled
there,
you should figure it out.
You know what I'm saying? Like like right off the hop, I don't
If she doesn't know that, that's
It's okay.
But she should understand
that when you go, "Hey, I'm looking for places to stay where
you live. Do you know like of good places to stay?" All right?
I'm just saying. >> have room. If you just want to
uh like room with me. >> So, Sekuna says, "I have room
if you just want to room with me." >> said, "And I at first
was not against it. I was like, 'Are you sure? Like, no, I I
don't want to
intrude. Like, I don't mind getting my own hotel and all this.'
Like, I was insistent on being like, 'Oh, no, it's fine.' And
then
>> Are we pretending
don't understand the cultural norm of like somebody offers you
something for free essentially,
because so, somebody offers you something essentially for free,
and you go, "Oh, no, I couldn't possibly intrude like that."
That is
That is like a thing that happens. And even from even on top
of that, okay,
even on top of that,
there is like a thing where
and this is I don't know who to blame for this, but women will
do this thing where they don't want to just immediately say,
"Oh, yeah, you could come You could come and stay with me."
And women go, "Oh, yeah, for sure."
Right? That doesn't happen. Women don't want to do that. They
don't want to be like easy, so they are like, "No, no, I couldn't
possibly."
>> He said, "No, no, no, like I have extra room. I already
paid for it." And I even asked him, I'm like, "Are you rooming
with a group
or with friends?" And he said, "No, but there's two beds, so
like you'll get your own bed." You know, like I
to me,
that is important.
Because to me, that is one of those scum moves, which I'm actually
disturbed by, which nobody seems to have picked out. And I picked
it out immediately.
She is going doing She is saying, in a nice way, to not treat
him like a pervert. She's going, "Well, I just want to make sure
you don't have
And he's going, "Yeah, look, I don't have intentions. Look, I
don't have intentions. You could come and there's not going to
be a
Right? So, in my opinion, that changes how it works a little
bit, assuming this is true.
>> Yeah. So, I took his offer.
>> Being a dumb ass, I took his offer, but I did later
I even offered to pay him back. I said, "Um how much should I
save up for accommodations?" And he said, "Oh, no.
No, no, no, you don't have to pay me back. Like I already have
room for the hotel. You don't have to pay me back. So, yeah,
I
>> shared a room with Sykkuno.
>> That's the big red flag? You think that's the big red
flag? I don't think so. Cuz again, we're going to get into this
later. I do believe Sykkuno had already bought her games and
a bunch of other [__] up to this point.
Sykkuno was already Sykkuno sets up a pay pig relationship like
immediately,
With attractive women. He's just He's pay pigging all of these
attractive women from like moment one. That's like his go-to
move to get them on the hook.
I'm telling you. I'm telling you. >> at Evo Las Vegas and
we had plans to watch a movie together. We had plans to watch
a horror movie together. Um Until Dawn. That movie's ass. Actually,
I didn't even get to finish it, but that movie's ass. >> Don't
make jokes. Don't make jokes. Don't make jokes. Don't make jokes.
Don't make jokes. I don't know what happened yet. It'd be really
bad taste if I found out that she's going to make like a full-on
allegation here and then I was making jokes about it, okay? So,
we're going to keep watching. No jokes. No jokes. No jokes. >> Um
he had a hotel you know he was in Vegas. Yes. Um
>> Yes. Um >> That should be a massive indicator.
Shouldn't that be huge? Shouldn't that be a massive red flag?
You're going to stay with some dude in Las Vegas. The guy lives
in Las Vegas.
He gets a hotel.
That I immediately But maybe I'm just you know, I I question
a lot of things. Maybe To me, I'm immediately I'm sitting here
and I'm like, "Dude, what? You're getting a getting a hotel?
>> Um but we were watching the movie
and he started to get very angsty or something. I don't know
how to explain
it, but he pretty much tried to make a move on me.
>> Angsty? Like what? What is I I'm telling you, there
is something this guy does that puts most women all the way off.
There's There's something he does that makes most women one-stop
shoppers with this guy despite getting like massive amounts of
money and a bunch of other
You'd think, to be honest, you'd think most of these women, just
for the sake of the clout, the for the sake of like the money
that he's like pay-pigging them a bunch, you'd think a lot of
them would just like kind of take it and just be like, "Oh, yeah.
I I kind of knew this was going to happen and yeah, this is what
I'm getting paid for." Honestly, I I I be shocked if at least
one woman didn't have that exact experience. I like, "Oh yeah,
well, it's going to
But a lot of women hang out with this guy and THEY'RE LIKE, "NO,
I DON'T WANT TO DO IT ANYMORE. NO, NO, it's not worth it." >> And
I was fully trying to say like I
I'm just here to watch a movie. Like I'm I'm just here to watch
a movie. >> I would be curious. Now, you're watching a
movie in a hotel room. There are two beds in the hotel room.
Why are you not in the other bed? Why why are you in the same
bed as him?
How did you Did you trip and fall into that bed? How did you
trip and fall into his bed? Or how did he trip and fall into
your
It's super easy. You just go, "Hey, there's two beds. Why don't
we swap and we'll just we'll just not be in the same bed." Yeah,
that's what I'm thinking is like did we get into a platonic?
Was there a tummy tickled here? We got a Katie bug situation.
There's a tummy tickled. I believe they're on a couch.
>> But me being a dumbass and not being
um very um like what's the word?
very strong
in like mentally. Not physically. I mean
um like I maybe this is a people pleaser in me, but um and maybe
I don't know benefit of the doubt or cuz I still thought he was
cute or I don't know. He tried to make a move on me resolute.
I don't know, but he he he made a move on me. It did take like
30 >> I don't Why did she say maybe it was because he was
cute? That That implies a lot right there. Do many dudes violate
boundaries even when you clearly establish them up front?
Um hmm.
Maybe Fran, but unfortunately there's like a we have to reckon
with the idea that there's this Puritan culture.
At least where I live, where I grew up, there's this like Puritan
culture, okay?
That women will tell you, "Oh, I'm not going to fuck." And then
they will come to your house with every intention to Matching
underwear and everything, okay? I'm sorry. I'm sorry. That is
something women do. They'll say, "I don't want to have sex."
And then they will show up with every intention of
okay? So, you could say you establish boundaries up front, but
sometimes there are I And I don't know how to reconcile that.
It's tough. It's tough. It's the I don't see anybody who's the
victor. That's why That's why we get paid the big bucks to go
through these situations and discuss them and figure it out,
right? Like you probably The thing I would say is if you If somebody
says, "Hey, we're not going to have sex tonight." and you're
just consistently
consistently wearing them down without having a conversation
explicitly saying, "Are you sure about this?" Maybe you could
say that's bad.
But I'm telling you, cuz I've I've gotten told this before, okay?
I'm I'm not joking. I've gotten told this before. That somebody
will tell me that and then I won't make a move and then they'll
be like, "Yeah, you know, I I just like guys who are like bold."
I'M BECOMING TECTONE,
OKAY? Holy [__] Holy [__] Now, listen,
I Maybe that's my problem is I always opt on the on the not Tectone
side of things, okay? Where I'm like, "Oh, you told me this."
So, it's literally the Louis C.K. joke. You guys have seen the
Louis C.K. joke before, right? It's literally I've been in that
situation. When I saw that Louis C.K. joke, I've I literally
couldn't believe it was so perfect.
It's like the same joke, okay? I think Oh, it's a little worse
for him. I've never been in that situation. Where like he's actively
like trying to escalate with some woman and she's like, "No,
no, don't don't do that. I'm done with that. No, we're not having
sex." And then later she tells him, "I just wanted you to GO
FOR IT."
YOU WANT me to
Are you on the off chance you're into that, eh? Okay, nope, never
again. Never again with this one. Yeah, sure, sure friend. I'm
just I'm saying.
I'm just saying. Yeah, yeah, I'm just I'm just saying. It's not
it Listen, it's a tough It's just tough to navigate. That's why
you look for other clues. Like when he said or when she
"Hey, is there like another bed? Hey, is there a group there?
Can I feel safe in that situation?" And he says something to
make her feel safe, to lure her in.
That's one of those things where I'm like, "Easy, that's not
good."
Sorry, we're we're back on her. >> Well, I don't want to
share that I don't like sharing this on This is like so
Like I don't talk about my intimate life at all, but um
I don't sleep with anyone that I'm not >> I don't Were
you dating him?
Wait, what? Wait, huh? I I uh-huh?
There's By the way, there is like You have to understand that
she's not even She's not even saying
this because she really thinks it. She's saying it because it's
like a It's like asking somebody what the weather is like or
or like commenting on the rain when you're in an elevator. Like
it's that level of like cultural nicety, culturally ingrained
thing. She's not even using her brain when she says this, right?
She's literally just going, "You know, I don't do this. I don't
sleep with people I don't date. I don't I never do this, right?"
It She's not even There's no brain engagement there. She's just
saying like, "I'm not over.
Okay, I'm just not."
>> I didn't want it to happen.
So, instead,
I just gave him
oral, okay? >> Dude, that's crazy. That's crazy.
I don't sleep with dudes who I don't date. Get Lav in here. Where's
Lav?
Where's Where's Lav talking about how disgusting that is. Girl,
that's your mouth or something.
Lab freaks the [__] out about this. Hold on, let's
roll it back real quick. Hear that again. >> It didn't
happen that night.
I didn't want it to happen.
So, instead
I just gave him
>> Dude, there needs to be like a woman's education that
says like this is the this is like horrible.
That that like you actually need females education so you guys
can learn like
technically just because you don't want to have sex, you shouldn't
blow the guy just cuz you don't want to have sex. That's actually
a mistake.
And I've heard this so many times it's insane. That's like well,
I didn't really like the guy that much so I just blew him. And
it's like
Wait, what?
WAIT WAIT, WHAT?
I I I swear there's like a normal thing for women like this is
honestly honestly God like a thing women do. They're like I don't
really like you the date didn't go well.
I guess I'll just blow it. It's like wait, what? Wait.
I just >> Bad signal. >> And then when he fell asleep,
I
got out of bed and I just ate a banana and I was just staring
out the window. I was dissociating. I think >> That that
can't be. Hold on. That can't be the cure to not think about
the traumatic you just gave to go grab a banana. That can't be.
Really? Where that's what we're doing now?
Am I the only person who heard that who heard that ordering of
events and I'm just like wait, what?
>> I was right up just dissociating.
And I'm >> dissociating. Okay. >> what just happened.
And then in the morning, I barely slept that night. Then in the
morning
um he didn't really want to talk about
>> And I was just kind of trying to open it up and talk
to him about like what
And then
>> That's I I really would like more clarity here on what
what you mean by opening it up to talk more about it. >> We
were going to talk about it
I don't know, later or something. I don't know, but I can't remember,
but he ends up hugging me, but then pushes me onto the bed. >> See,
this is why again, firm boundaries would be good. Cuz she she's
saying that she felt like she didn't want to blow him, but she
did. And then
BB Poison, please, I'm trying to prevent incels here and you're
not helping. The real take is she blew him because of the stress
of having to find her own hotel room immediately is too stressful
of a thing for her to deal with. Let's be real. As in, the idea
of her like she literally it was like, well, if I refuse to blow
him and he kicks me out, then I have to go find and that's just
a lot of work. That's just a lot You know what?
I got my toothpaste here. It'll be fine. It'll be fine.
>> from the hug.
And we end up having sex.
This is why the the the get out of in the first place is a bad
idea. Sends the wrong signal.
didn't have it in me to tell him to
So I just let it happen. And while this was happening, while
we were doing it,
um I always wear protection and I only sleep with people I'm
in relationship with, so I'm not used to one-night stands or
anything like that.
Um but we were not using protection and I'm legally hard of hearing,
if you guys
Uh mhm.
>> don't know already. Um but in the heat of the moment,
he asked me if it was safe and I didn't hear him, but I just
said, "Mhm." And he finished
inside of me and then that was it. And
um we just laid there for a little bit and then I brought it
up. I asked him,
that's like a tough situation.
That is a tough situation. I Like listen, that's a tough situation
that
that like that could be a thing she's quite upset about. I I
mean it's justifiable to be upset about that if you're a woman,
right?
Like that puts your body under a lot of stress to
have guy come inside of you. It's like something you could be
upset about. It sounds like an honest
So, we'll keep listening. >> I asked him straight up,
"When was your last relationship
and do you sleep around often? Like is this normal for you?"
Because I told him straight up, "I do not date with people I
do not sleep with people I do not date. I do not sleep with people
that I do not date. That is just a moral of mine." >> Okay,
so now I see a split in what could possibly be happening here,
okay? Hold on.
Now, is she saying that she is pressing him for a relationship
or is she saying that I don't [__] around, so you
don't have to think that you have an STD, but if you [__]
around, I want to know so I know that I don't have an STD.
Which of these two realms are we entering and will we get more
clarification as we go along?
>> Um I find it very um intimate with whoever. So, and
I don't actually have um I've only slept with ever like I've
only ever slept with three people. Well, four now. But, I've
only been with in three relationships.
it was very new to me. I've never had a one-night stand or anything
like that.
I asked him, I'm like, "Do you Is this normal for you? Like,
do you sleep around a lot?" And he said, "No, I just
He He was beating around the bush the whole time that I was asking
these questions, by the way. I'm like, "Then why did you sleep
with me?" And he said, "Oh, it just You know, giving me really
half-assed answers, you
Like, "Oh, it's just, you know, I've known you for a while, and
I know you're very sweet, and you know, you look nice." And then
I
>> this question, and and I said, "When was your last relationship?"
And he said, "3 years ago." So, in my head,
it's crazy to That's why I feel so blindsided and backstabbed
because I asked these questions.
>> The amount of fully grown women that think cream pie
equals we're dating is concerning. I mean,
Is it that or is it that they don't want like the risk of, you
know, possibly having to deal with a pregnancy with somebody
they have no emotional stability from? Like, I see the other
side of it, too. I get the other side of that. >> And they
ended up being complete lies.
So, when I really felt black blindsided and backstabbed by all
the information that was coming out, I really was because I asked
those two questions like if he was in a relationship or like
when his last relationship was, and
if he >> She's saying she didn't consent in the first place.
I believe her that like it was just a dubious consent situation
that she wasn't totally sure about.
But now that she feels lied to, she feels like, "Well, the things
that made me feel more okay and not used in this situation were
lies. They're now proven to be lies, so I want to go talk about
it." So, I Again, I don't think this is like a allegation. That
That's how I'm seeing it, okay?
But it is like retroactively the things that made her okay with
the situation are false, are lies, obvious lies. So, she feels
used, she feels manipulated,
and she's upset about it.
Through deception. I mean, I'm not making that argument really.
It's um
But I understand how that would be like kind of emotionally as
well to find out that this guy who did all this stuff was just
like lying to you the whole time. >> He sleeps around and
he told me no and 3 years ago.
um after that
I went on about my day um and then
I ended up not I ended up um running into someone I'm very close
with and they offered me to stay in their
hotel room
because I didn't feel comfortable sleeping in mine. So, I ended
up sleeping at my friend's hotel room for the next two nights
and you guys
Um I mean, that sort of lends credence to the idea that she was
not really into
No? Did he also get a BJ? Wait, is I don't have any reason to
believe it's a
But I'm just I'm asking is it Does that not lend credence to
the idea that she was uncomfortable by or with what happened?
That that it wasn't something she felt like she wanted to happen.
Again, she I I feel like that lends some strength to her allegat-
like her allegation. But again, I don't think that from what
I'm hearing here, it's not like Sykuno's a Sykuno's like the
kind of person who is not actively making sure the person's like
enthusiastically consenting, which is bad, but it's not like
um it's not like, you know, violently ignoring consent or whatever.
And it's it is like a lot of misreading signals. >> You
guys can even tell. >> Run that back or run it back 30
seconds. >> no and 3 years ago. >> No and 3 years
ago is no, I'm not dating anybody yet now and my last relationship
was 3 years ago.
um after that
I went on about my date um and then
I ended up not I ended up um running into someone I'm very close
with and they offered me to stay in their
hotel room
because I didn't feel comfortable sleeping in mine. So, I ended
up sleeping at my friend's hotel room for the next 2 nights.
And you guys can even tell you guys can even see on uh Twitter
if you guys look at my Evo outfits. The first outfit is in a
very different hotel room than the other two and that's because
I ended up moving to another hotel. The first one is in the one
that I'm with Saku no. And um I ended up sleeping >> Unfortunately,
we can't check any of these things cuz she's privated all of
her social media.
I I laughed cuz I saw there's a clip of Deckers like getting
asked to go check the outfits and it's like, well, uh maybe I
should be ready to do that and then I checked that all the social
media's privated. So, no way to check. No way to look. >> in
the hotel that me and Saku no had on the last night because he
ended up checking out early and sleeping at his
So, that was the only time I saw him.
We ran into each other a couple of more times at Evo, but we
didn't really say anything and
he didn't really want to talk about what
And then
>> So, like why doesn't he want to talk if if she's feeling
uncomfortable about
why wouldn't he want to talk about what happened? What like that's
another thing that makes me think something weird happened here
is if he if he this girl blew him the first night then at sex
then he like had sex with her the next morning
and then she doesn't want to be around him anymore. Is that not
making you feel like turbo weird as a dude? Does that just feel
like, oh, everything's cool?
You're like you you just had sex with this girl. She came to
Evo like to stay with you and she's staying at a different place
now after you had sex. Does that not ring Is there not a single
light that goes on there and you're like, hey, what the What?
Huh?
No? Nothing? >> I struggled with this for a while
and I had someone in my life um be there for me and kind of try
to help me through this.
dumbass um tried talking about it with Sykkuno later. Trying
to like
something I'm used to.
And um he
he pretty much beat around the bush the whole time.
Um and then he he would say things like, oh, I I'm confused.
I just wanted to know what you felt about that. And I said, no,
I want to know what you felt about this because >> Holy
[__]
Do we
I feel like if like at some point if we ever get to like the
Black Mirror stage of society, we should figure out people who
talk like this in private who are like totally incapable of actually
having a straightforward conversation and we should tax them
massively. They make any amount of income, they should just be
like, listen, you're not allowed to have like large amounts of
capital. Like you don't get to have that if you can't have a
real conversation in It's actually crazy. >> I already
told you how I felt and yeah, he said he was sorry that he made
me he he was sorry that he gave me that
and that he would want to reconcile and my me being the dumbass
I am, I still wanted to be >> What impression? >> friends
with him for some reason. >> What impression? >> I
did and that's why we still played
And then I ended up seeing him at TwitchCon at the Riot party
and we actually talked in person for the first time since.
And he actually brought that part up and said like he was sorry
and stuff and that he was sorry for giving me the impression.
So I really thought he would >> What impression? That makes
me think so
That makes me think that she was
So you put this together. I'm now leaning towards she does think
that he wanted to date her. Right? That they were looking for
a
Right? That's That's the only impression I think he could have
given that was weird. What's the There's no other impression
that you could have given like in the amount of time what we've
heard described. There's another clip. There's three more clips,
okay. Twitch streamer Leeah breaks down her DMs with Sykkuno
after being exposed for being a serial cheater on Twitter and
claims he prays on small young female creators using his status
powers
Uh dude, the money thing to me feels like it doesn't work. The
money thing for a lot of these girls who are like on social media
and trying to do the streamer thing. I think the money thing
is probably not as big a deal as people make it, even them. I
Honestly, if you're a young attractive woman, you can usually
get money from a lot of different places like doing sort of the
same thing.
I don't think that really separates. It's the status thing. It's
the status. It's the he's a famous streamer.
That's what it is.
>> When we were actually playing together
the day everything came out. Or like we were we were planning
on not the day we were planning on playing the TFT box the box
box boot camp together.
We were planning on playing TFT
And then he messaged me that morning with everything coming out
and said sorry, I have a lot going on. And then I said, yeah,
I saw everything on Twitter. Is it true?
This is the only thing I will read from our DMs. I said Well,
he said the day of, also I'm sorry I'm going through a lot. And
I said, yeah, I just saw on Twitter.
He said, do you want to talk for a second? I said, um I don't
really know. I'm still processing everything. I feel overwhelmed.
It honestly really hurt like I've been backstabbed.
We've known each other for over 6 years and I generally thought
our friendship was real and that we were reconciling.
He said, you don't have to. I'm sorry, I just wanted to explain.
It's not as simple as you would see it, but I understand.
I said, I don't know if I can get into a call with you right
now, >> There's no way she's older than early
Ah, I don't think this is her bedroom. This isn't the room she
streams from most often.
Hold on a second. I'll see if I can find one of her other streams.
This isn't her bedroom. I feel like she must be home. Is it a
holiday? The 10th? No.
I don't know why she'd be home.
But this this is like not the room she normally streams from.
Uh let's see here. This is the stream This is the stream she
normally or the setup she normally has. It's like here, like
this.
Is that uh thank you. >> I'll be honest, this Asian woman
could be anywhere from like 20 to 20 nine.
There's just no way to carbon date Asian women, okay? Just doesn't
work. Can't >> like to hear your side and give you time
to explain.
He said, okay, thank you. And I said, sorry, I have a lot to
do today today. This is literally the day that the night
that I had to pack
um and get my kids ready to come here. Did I do any of that?
No.
I said, sorry, I have a lot to do the day before I leave, so
I won't have time to call, but if I And I honestly didn't feel
comfortable calling him. I said, if I could have just have some
explanation to ease my mind, that would be nice. And he said,
that's okay, I can give you the short version. To be honest,
I was in a bad relationship for a long time. We hadn't like spent
time together, slept together, anything for several years. But
she relied on me for a place to live and I paid for everything
for her and I still cared, so I didn't break up. I should have.
I generally think you're amazing and none of that was fake. I
can talk more later, but I haven't made sure she will be I I
I can talk more later, but I have to I have already made sure
she will be okay. He's talking about his girlfriend.
I said,
"I can sympathize with you a little as I was in a similar situ-
a similar relationship as you before, so I know it can be
hard to break things off since you don't want to hurt their feelings
knowing you're fully supporting them, too, but that doesn't excuse
>> Yeah, he's saying with his current girlfriend they didn't
sleep together in I feel like that's I mean, I guess that kind
of can happen.
Like the dead bedroom situation. That's rough when you're like
in a
That I I don't know what that's like technically, but I'm I'm
saying I was going to say when you're young, but he's not that
young. I was going to say that's rough to get into when you're
like 20, but he's 35 or something, so actually never mind. >> excuse
your actions to go behind your girlfriend's back and cheat on
her. I know you know this now, but you should have had the decency
to end your relationship with her before talking and sleeping
with other girls. It's hard for me to believe if any of it was
genuine as you were talking to multiple girls at the same time
and doing the exact same thing to them as you did to me. I remember
I even asked you whether you slept around with other people often
after we did it and when your last relationship was and you said
no and it your last relationship was 3 years ago. You lied to
me.
He said, "You're right. I'm not saying an excuse. I was just
sharing how I got there. I'm sorry if you don't believe me, that's
understandable."
>> Wait, he she does believe you. That's why it's all really
[__] up. Wait, everybody believes you now. Everyone
believes you now.
Saikou note, "Wait, I'm sorry if you don't believe me. No, I
believe that you're like a piece of [__] I've seen
the evidence."
Very goofy. >> "Thank you for at least listening a little
listening to me a little." And then I said, "I'm not saying that
I don't believe you, but why weren't you just honest with me?"
And he never replied. Pretty >> That's That's all I'm saying.
I guarantee you all every single one of these women
Dude, I Saikou no doesn't get it and it's weird that he doesn't
get it cuz you'd think with like the amount of times he was talking
to different women, he would start to get it. He never had to
lie.
He He literally never had to lie. He probably had to lie about
the relationship, but he didn't have to lie about his intentions.
He could have said, "I'm a rolling stone. I [__]
That's the way it is. And all of the same women who would have
gone and talked to him would have done the same thing.
Just be normal. Just say, "Yeah."
He might have Honest to god, he might have done better if he
just said, "Yeah, I you know, I
I pal around."
If he'd said [__] like this, he might have done better
with these women. I'm not even joking.
I don't know. It's It's very weird that he felt the need to lie
about this. >> Mhm. The just of it.
and I think that's where the sympathy >> Sorry, he didn't
He didn't lie cuz Oh, actually somebody just said, "I mean, he'd
probably find plenty of home wreckers, too." Actually, when I
said he had to lie, it was not because I thought women wouldn't
sleep with him knowing he was married or knowing he was in a
relationship. That's actually not what I meant. He had to lie
so that the nature of that relationship didn't become public
and he wasn't getting like blackmailed by these women. Like he
didn't want them to know that he was in a relationship because
he didn't want to feel like they had something on him. That's
why he lied about it, right? That's what the lie That's why he
had to lie. It's not cuz he wouldn't have found women who wanted
to [__] him anyway. It's cuz he doesn't want to give
them that power.
There's nothing to unpack. >> I still thought it was very
wrong and I even told him that he should have had the decency
that she uh not to cheat on his girlfriend and break up with
her first when he wanted to hire you and prey on small female
streamers because he knows his status. And that's why I was so
scared to share my story because I see so many girls um just
saying their like sharing their stories and then everyone just
saying, "Okay, he's just a a serial cheater." That's all it is.
Yeah, he is a serial cheater, but he used his status, his
>> God, I These women all speak about this in the exact
in the exact wrong way to be taken seriously online. His powers,
his his status, his powers.
I swear, just write something down.
For the love of God, write something down. Holy Cuz I understand
this is how he understands women like I do, okay? I swear. But
it's like I know exactly what she's doing. She feels like really
[__] up because this guy lied to her, okay? She feels
really [__] up. She thinks it's a good idea to go
live and just share how [__] up she feels.
It's not. It's a terrible idea for you specifically. Is there's
literally no worse idea for you than just going live and talking
about the way you feel? It's rough. Yeah, he used his powers.
Cuz you say stuff like that and then it just sounds goofy and
then everyone makes fun of you.
It's it's tough. But I understand that she feels taken advantage
of and she feels like she was predated on, like she was lied
to. She was told this exact story that she doesn't like, you
know, she feels really used, she feels really like worthless
after hearing everything that's come out, right? And she thinks,
oh, I'll go I'll go live and I'll just talk about it. And I'm
not going to lie, I'm just going to say how I feel. It's like,
dude, you There are a whole bunch of people who are going to
record this, make copies, and then meticulously analyze every
single pause in dialogue throughout this whole thing to know
what you're trying to hold back, okay? Like the level to the
which this is going to be picked apart
is silly. All right? No, I don't need to tell her how to express
it. I'm just saying this is not going to have a good effect.
It's not going to be It's going to be like weaponized against
you super hard. Like
I wish they'd understand that before they go and do it.
Cuz I I again, when I hear all of this, I I don't hear that like
she was assaulted. I don't hear that.
I hear that she is now retroactively she's retroactively evaluating
the situation knowing that she was lied to knowing that when
she said hey did you like like this is just the thing you trusted
this person okay
now you realize that they've been lying to you a lot so when
you said when you said well I didn't feel like I I feel like
I made it clear that you shouldn't come inside of me okay if
I think I made it clear and he goes no but I asked you and you
now think he's a liar
well obviously
the fact that you now think he's a liar it affects everything
right that's now you think this guy's a liar and now you're not
sure did he even say anything did you just get gaslit cuz he
lies so
so like the idea that you can't retroactively like evaluate a
situation
and realize something up happened that's just silly it's very
silly okay um that's entirely possible that if they got together
and spoke her that that if Saikou no said all I want to date
now that this would never been a problem but I do think that
it would have always been a problem if she found out how much
he was lying to get her into bed that is the that is the issue
here that is like the victimhood the victimization she feels
is that she was lied to and she trusted this guy so much so that
even after this happened she wanted to still be friends and she
was like kind of moving past it telling herself she was crazy
and then you get somebody basically proving to you that you weren't
crazy you were right to feel like this guy wasn't concerned about
you wasn't taking your well-being into account and now you're
like letting that out that feeling out
makes sense
that's why I think like my job is mostly to go through and say
like well it's why I don't think I don't think you could really
judge him in terms of this consent stuff necessarily yet but
it's um
yeah I think a lot of people are talking about this like it's
a re-evaluation I just don't see it
>> a lot of them being really young like 19 20 I mean we
met when I was 19 I mean nothing happened until like the last
within the last 2 years. Um >> Oh, it's just shocking to
me. You Mr. Girl had that like strip club hypothetical. It's
just shocking to me how so many guys
whenever they get power immediately go to just change 18 and
19-year-olds.
Like, isn't that isn't that weird? Isn't that like telling somehow
that the second someone gets power after not being have not being
very successful in their like early 20s, they just immediately
go to change the hottest 18 and 19-year-olds they can. It It's
just wild to me. It's almost like there's some sort of psychic
barrier holding these people back from dipping even lower. It's
almost like there's a legal barrier of some kind and that if
these people were given the opportunity they would dip even lower
if they could.
I just I'm just saying. I'm just saying.
That's what it seems like.
Every dude gets power and then they just change the youngest
person the youngest class of people they can. Very strange how
it always seems to come out that
They just say that out loud? No, they don't. No, they don't.
No, they don't. Most people don't say that.
And it's crazy the reason why I felt so blindsided and hurt by
this it's because for a long time it was me and Tycoon were actually
just really good friends. Like nothing bad happened until the
last 2 years
um of our friendship.
And and when I asked those questions if he was in a relationship
and whether he sleeps around a lot and he him telling me his
last relationship was 3 years ago and no he doesn't sleep around.
He told me that to my face after we did it. Was I expecting anything
>> Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, >> and whether
he sleeps around a lot him telling me his last relationship was
3 years ago and no he doesn't sleep around. He told me that to
my face. >> Oh, no, I'm seeing a hutch moment right here.
Why is she doing the anime face? The like blowing out your cheeks
anime face. It's like I I'm not a fan, man. I'm not a fan. >> After
we did it. Was I expecting
like a relationship? No.
But to think like and I believed him. I believed him and I said
But always after that incident, I was always like there was a
lot of unanswered questions
and I was very um
confused by it all.
>> I honestly feel worse sharing. I don't know why. I I
don't like um sharing my personal life and experience online.
I still feel too I still feel somehow I'm talking
>> The cat bread thing is far >> airing out business
and drama and I hate drama and business. So yeah, I actually
kind of feel like [__] right now.
Um but I think down the line it
I'll feel better, but
I feel very exposed.
>> Dude. Twitch streamer Lea wants to get tested after
finding out Saikou no lied and slept around with multiple girls
and reveals she did take Plan B. Okay.
I assume so. I hope so. I hope she's enough of an adult to do
that. Are you just going to roll the dice on that one? >> It's
crazy
cuz I remember Bear and Jenna telling me oh, be careful. Bear
and Jenna are the only ones that knew that I would be sharing
a hotel with him and they told me like be careful, you know,
like >> Does that not I mean, it's I I know this now, but
now I don't have any friends that are young enough to like benefit
from the wisdom. But if I heard like a female friend describing
this to me I I would be like, you need a plan for when
you see his knowing that you don't want that. Like the second
you see a you need to start screaming and like flailing about
or something, okay? I need you to understand that if you see
a you just need to start screaming and flailing all over the
place until whatever is happening stops because I'm telling you
you're going to be in like some kind of trance and when you see
a you need to immediately just start flailing around cuz that's
the only way to get out of that situation.
Like this is your wake up. I'm I'm putting a counter spell on
you, okay? It is a it is a time curse.
No, I'm just saying if you actually don't want to if you do want
to then whatever, it's fine. Don't feel like you have to tell
everybody you don't.
But I'm just saying like yeah. Everybody has a plan a plan until
they have a in their face and then it's
you know, old Mike Tyson quote. Something like that. >> Be
careful and guess what? My dumb ass was like no, I know him.
>> Wait, everybody has a plan until they take a shot in
the mouth is what Mike Tyson said almost verbatim, okay? And
it also applies to this situation. >> I'm like I've known
him for 6 years. Like we're just friends. Like nothing's going
to happen. They warned me.
And it's crazy cuz after that all happened that morning of I
remember calling Jenna
on the phone and crying
for like 2 hours
telling her how disgusting
I felt and how
>> Like realistically the thing I'm picking up here is
more that this woman doesn't have like a she doesn't have like
a modern
like feeling of morality around like she thinks and I'm not saying
she's wrong but her like feeling around is just totally discordant
with her having with somebody the first night she stays with
And she let it happen cuz this guy's rich and he's famous and
he likes her and they've been friends and she's like kind of
comfortable and then it sort of gets there.
But it sounds like she just feels like like she just has all
of the shame for just having sex. That's not she sounds like
a normie. Well, sure this could be normie. I'm just I'm not even
judging it. I'm just saying it sounds almost more like she just
feels like gross and that she probably would have felt gross
no matter what in this situation. >> I blamed myself. I
like I was like I feel so disgusted.
I remember
crying to Gianna about it. I actually literally like
Yeah, I was dissociating that whole trip. I think with the news
coming out, I had that same feeling.
Not only
did I find out that I wasn't the only one and I'm not saying
like oh, I'm the only one like that was with him. Like I don't
care about that. I mean like he slept with so many other people
and now and I remember when all the news came out um >> What
does she mean by dissociating?
I I do think that it's just her grappling with the idea that
she
made that trade-off. I don't know what happened the next morning.
The next morning sounds a little worse than the previous night.
But then she was like damn, I really should have I really should
have just got a hotel.
It's like having a bad conversation with somebody you're friends
with or like you get in a fight or something with somebody and
then you're like re-evaluating the fight after.
I don't think she truly means dissociating. I think she means
like she's in her head like ruminating on the same event over
and over again and why she did why it didn't play out the way
she wanted.
I don't think that's dissociating. Dissociating means something
else. When she says dissociating, I assume she means like ruminating.
She cannot be like she cannot like get into the moment because
she is spinning in her head thinking why did I end up doing that
thing I don't do. >> I remember calling my therapist just
crying and telling her about everything and I didn't tell her
about this because I was so ashamed. That's what I felt. I was
so ashamed
and disgusted of myself that I let that
And then I remember like she was like do you feel disgusted like
because
you didn't have control of your body like you were in control
and now finding out that he slept with multiple girls. Like I
had never got tested.
The only thing I did um
is I went and got Plan B by myself
after we did it because I was like no in I've I've never slept
without protection.
So I went and got Plan B all by myself, paid for it and everything
which I mean I don't give a [__]
I would
I dude I um I'm sitting here
I'm sitting here just like you know, she is a she's a victim
of the first time she had unprotected being with Saiko no who
I'm getting the very strong impression is just a terrible lay
by all by all accounts every single like non direct indicator
I have says this guy can't first and the first time she has unprotected
is with him. He he ruined it man. He ruined it. It's [__]
up. >> But I wanted to be safe or as safe as I could be.
But never in my mind did I think that I would have to get tested
and I feel like now I want to get tested because now I'm scared
that
what if I have something and I don't
>> Okay, so when she's talking about getting tested this
does feel like another big reason you shouldn't be lying about
partners. There is a health element of it that is really [__]
up to do in my opinion. Right? It's not That's why it's like
none of your business. Yeah, sure it's none of my business who
your partners are. Don't tell me their names. Don't tell me their
identities, but you better say and give me a reasonably like
truthful answer on how much you and how often you [__]
without
Did she ask him? Yes. And he lied.
And I don't and it sounds like she has logs asking him again
why did you lie and he goes yeah I did lie.
You know what I'm saying? So again, nobody has the right to know
who your partners are, but if you are going to try to have sex
with somebody, you do have a I believe an obligation to be truthful
about how much you have sex and how often you have sex without
And lying about that, I it's just scummy move. Again, another
scumbag move. And this one, you know, this is one of those ones
where I'm I'm cultured on the side of like just lying in general
to women to try to is wrong, like really wrong, cuz it causes
this whole spiral of like now this woman is way less like trusting
of her future partner, has way more barriers up. It's like we
justify like psychically scarring people just because we don't
want to have what? Again, because we don't want to prevent, you
know, I might be famous one day and I want to change year olds
and I don't want to take these criticisms. I don't want to have
to deal with this. So, actually it's just always fine to lie
to have sex. It's like not cool. Not cool.
That is what I hear when I hear the
It's like actually ruins relationships for everybody.
Don't do it. Be a better person than >> Guys, I did mention
that my monitors were all gifted and yes, Trev did gift me my
recent monitor.
Okay, but the other two monitors, which also Trev, you're the
goat, thank you. But the other two monitors that I did get when
I moved back here were from
He did send me money um for >> Dude, Sykkuno was propping
up like the entire Twitch e-girl ecosystem single-handedly.
Okay?
That's a real
All right, he he was investing in every single e-girl to keep
them streaming, okay? The the person The e-girl perception online
is actually just totally constructed by Sykkuno. He's like 80%
of the e-girl economy, all right? He's just slipping all these
women money constantly to keep
But not once did I ask for money. Not once. I never asked him
to send me money. I >> I don't understand why we got to
why we got to cap like this. Why you got to
Why you why you got to cap like this? I just don't get it.
Okay, I didn't Listen, he never he never ever ever ever or sorry,
I never ever ever asked him for money. Okay, but did you go to
the rich guy who buys you stuff and go, "Man, my monitors really
suck. I can't believe that I've got these monitors. I My monitor's
like dying and things are like really
and I don't know what to do. I don't know what to do."
>> I just woke up one day and I had a a message and he
said, "I hope you I hope that's enough for your monitors." And
I said, "What the hell? That's
>> "I hope that's enough for your monitors." How did he
know ABOUT YOUR
HE JUST DIVINED THE need for monitors. He just came up with that
out of
>> too much money. I can't." And he said, "No, no, it's
okay. Don't worry." Like yeah.
I just want to reiterate, not once did I ever ask anything from
him, okay? And
yes, it's all in the DMs.
>> I also never sent him explicit photos, okay? Or >> Oh,
okay.
Explicit photos.
Hold on. Hold on. Is stochastic begging? Yeah, basically.
Hold on though. Hold on.
I've never sent him explicit photos. And then there's like this
pause and I'm like, wait.
What kind of photos were you sending? Were you sending some kind
of photos to him? Maybe not like super Like I just feel like
when you sent
when you sent like when when you posted something new on Instagram,
were you sending him pictures, too? Like the pictures on your
Instagram?
I do feel like there's something going on there if you do that.
>> Um or like I know some girls were in that regard. Um
I never did
>> I sent Bebe Boiss my address. That's what I sent. I
was like, "Listen, if you're if you're like if you have donated
to the stream explicitly with the purpose of getting my address
so you can come kill me, then you won, okay? If that's cuz you'd
already gifted like 100 subs or 200 subs or something at that
point a few months into the stream. I was like, "Listen, if you
were just planning to kill me,
you you won. You cracked the code. All right, you cracked the
code totally. You could just kill you could do it, okay? That's
that's what the address is. You trust him with your address?
Yeah, cuz to get it shipped somewhere else was just going to
be in effect it was going to be with customs.
So, yeah, I was just like, "Listen, you you got me. If that's
all you want is to kill me, you got me on this one." >> Or
sent him explicit photos. Um especially when I was in a relationship.
I mean like at all. I never did. Um Well, I obviously
did probably at one point found him
>> She was in a relationship when they were first friends.
That's another reason that things might have been a little bit
different. When they first met, she was in a relationship for
some number of years, I think.
>> And I think that definitely clouded my judgment, too.
Because I'm like, this guy is showering me with
money and gifts and stuff that I never asked for. And I think
I I did have a crush at crush on him at one point.
Um or liked him, but
I never knew it was going to I I knew Sorry. I knew it was never
going to
Yes, because he's so much older than me. So, I just want to say
even though >> He's not that much older than you. I guess
when they first met, she's 20 and he's 30, so maybe
maybe then you feel like he's that much older, but now it's later.
Okay. I I I'll give it to her when they first met. She's like
19 or 20, he's like 29 30. That's like a way bigger age gap.
>> Oh, I may have liked him and had a crush on him. >> 25
and 35 now. >> voiced it. >> I never >> Most
of that. >> told him.
I never did any of that because one, I knew he was older than
me.
And I just me being insecure, I'm like, this guy would never
like me. Like Like I'm and I'm not saying that in like a I don't
know, like a pick me behavior. I just generally I'm like No,
like You know, like >> All right, that's not what pick
me >> to sound like come off that way, but like I'm just
[__] insecure.
So, I just was like, yeah, he he never he's he's never seen me
like this. He's never going to see me like that. And I am okay
with that because I also know that he's older than me and that
it's just like, oh, I just think he's good-looking. Like I just
think he's cute. That's it. But not once did I ever ask for anything.
>> Okay, we've got the roommate thing.
Got the roommate thing and then we're going to go into some of
the reactions.
My opinion, very funny.
That her ex-roommate she she jumps on the slandering allegations
and her ex-roommate
apparently had some allegations of her own about what a [__]
roommate and friend this person is. So, they popped out and were
like, hey, listen, if this woman's going to be in the news, then
I got some comments of my
Getting Me Too'd, so to speak, on the Me Too allegations. Kind
of [__] up, man. It's a little [__] up.
All right. So, Tenpo, this is apparently her former roommate,
okay?
Not surprised this is happening. Again.
I lived together with Lea, her sister, and a few other creators
back in 2024. At some point her ex, who was a bigger creator,
broke up with her. Her ex was supporting was financially supporting
her. Everything was paid for. She wasn't streaming, wasn't working,
and what was just staying in bed most days. After the breakup,
she came to me for help and advice. I spent hours talking to
her, losing sleep trying to support her, telling her to focus
on herself, build her own stability, love herself first, and
not center her whole life around her ex. I wanted to help someone
who I thought was a friend.
She didn't take any of that advice. Instead, she actively did
the opposite, putting all her energy into trying to get him back
by any means necessary.
She spent more money on a makeover and would even dress up in
a certain way when we went to the gym together. She was desperate.
When that didn't work, instead of taking accountability for her
own choices, all the blame got pushed onto me by the end of our
lease somehow. The person who was trying to help them, both her
and her sister turned it into something it wasn't and would even
start spreading false rumors about me or about everyone involved
with their messy breakup that year. This would bleed into 2025.
Now I'm watching a very similar situation unfold again, and once
again, it involves a bigger creator. Same pattern, same outcome,
no
At some point, actions have to have consequences or at some point,
actions have consequences.
Well, I mean, is this the same I don't know if this is the same
thing.
This just sounds like a totally unrelated thing. You're like,
oh, it's the same kind of allegation.
That it sort of centers around a bigger creator, maybe?
Uh I don't I don't sleep with people I don't date. We had sex
and we weren't dating. I always use protection. He pissed out
of me, didn't use protection. I'm not easy. It only took 30 minutes
to talk me into giving him oral. Can't make this [__]
up. Yeah. It's so easy, man. It's just so easy.
It's so easy to just like
I understand the idea of, okay, well, we need accountability
for women. And it's like, dude, I can say she made really bad
choices. She obviously made really bad choices. It would be really
cool to have women understand that you're making bad choices
from like every every stage of this pipeline, you're making terrible
decisions.
But I I do have something to say for people who take advantage
of people who are like
It's the same thing with Unfortunately, not to turn it into Israel-Palestine,
but it's the same thing with Bibi Netanyahu and Trump. Just because
Trump is a total
and has the ultimate call on whether or not America like strikes
something, doesn't mean he wasn't manipulated, doesn't mean he
wasn't used, doesn't mean anything.
Okay? It doesn't mean I don't get to cast blame because he had
the final say.